bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct notre grand témoin ce soir nous
éclaire sur la guerre en Ukraine bonsoir
Michel gauguard merci d'être là ancien
colonel des troupes de marine et
historiens militaires vous publiez avec
le journaliste Jean Lopez l'ours et le
renard chez Perrin l'ours c'est l'ours
russe c'est le renard le renard
ukrainien envahir revenir vous nous
faites pénétrer au cœur des combats avec
les forces et les faiblesses des armées
de part et d'autre on en parlera en ce
jour d'ouverture du sommet de l'OTAN à
Vilnus on en parle ensemble tout à
l'heure mais on commence ce soir par la
reconstruction c'est pour l'heure la
seule annonce concrète du président de
la République le projet de loi d'urgence
pour réparer au plus vite les dégâts
causés par les violences
urbaines il sera débattues dans le
courant de la semaine prochaine à
l'Assemblée la facture est très salée
elle s'élève à des centaines de millions
d'euros alors qui va payer grand débat
avec mes invités dans un instant sur ce
plateau avant de retrouver nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris avec un
Richard Verly en duplex de Vilnius ce
soir pour le sommet de l'OTAN et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le
programme on y va Michel Goya ça vous
regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
plus de 1000 bâtiments atteints plus de
200 écoles de très très nombreux
commerces aussi ciblés le gouvernement
ouvre donc le chantier national de la
reconstruction mesures techniques pour
accélérer les travaux et débats très
politiques aussi ou droites et gauche
s'opposent sur qui doit payer bonsoir
Louis Marguerite et bienvenue sur ce
plateau député renaissance de
Saône-et-Loire
Chalon-sur-Saône dans votre
circonscription Montceau-les-Mines Torcy
ciblées par ses par ses nuits de
violence bonsoir Sabrina sebahi
bienvenue à vous députés
européropéologie les Verts des
Hauts-de-Seine Nanterre épicentre
évidemment des violences après la mort
de Naël tuée par un policier bonsoir
Jean-Philippe dugouin Clément ravi de
vous retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
mère divers droites du Mennecy
udi vous faites bien de préciser celles
dans les sols également touché par les
émemes d'urbaines enfin bonsoir Philippe
allauze bonsoir bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes le président de la Chambre
syndicale des buralistes 250 le chiffre
qu'on a retenu d'après Bruno Le Maire 23
234 bureaux de tabac ciblé dans le pays
vous faites bien de France uniquement en
Île-de-France et on a le chiffre
national le chiffre national avoisine
les 530
de me corriger Michel Goya évidemment ce
qui s'est passé dans le pays nous saisit
tous n'hésitez pas à réagir ou même
interroger nos invités on commence par
planter le décor avec Stéphane
blackovski ou camarade comme chaque soir
il a deux secondes pour nous dire ce que
prévoit ce projet de loi on l'accueille
tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
retourner tous alors ce projet de loi et
bien ce soir on parle donc du dernier
projet de loi qui sera débattu à
l'Assemblée avant les vacances en
l'occurrence le projet de loi pour
accélérer le projet de loi d'urgence
d'ailleurs pour accélérer la
reconstruction donc comme son nom
l'indique il s'agit de faciliter la
reconstruction du millier de bâtiments
qui ont été soit détruits soit au moins
abîmés par les émeutiers là on essaie on
espère le faire en réduisant les délais
administratifs d'autorisation diverses
comme on avait fait pour reconstruire
Notre-Dame comme on l'a proposé pour
l'industrie verte pour construire des
usines plus facilement donc dire que
dans le cas des émeutes les dégâts sont
tout à fait considérables vous disiez
plusieurs centaines de millions le
dernier chiffre donné par les assureurs
vous voyez c'est 650 millions et ce
n'est pas un chiffre définitif puisque
toutes les déclarations de sinistre
n'ont pas encore été envoyées le Medef
lui fait une évaluation en disant ça va
finir autour de 1 milliard donc ce
chiffre même s'il n'est pas définitif
les assureurs font du d'ores et déjà
remarqué régler à ce stade trois fois
plus important que les émeutes qui ont
eu lieu en 2005 donc vous voyez
l'ampleur des émeutes aussi apparaît à
travers ce chiffre sont plutôt les
commerces en tout cas en termes de
montant des dégâts qui ont été touchés
avant les bâtiments publics et puis donc
les véhicules donc comme vous le disiez
sont les bureaux de tabac les plus
frappés en deuxième les agences
bancaires alors évidemment dans une
situation pareille le gouvernement
s'efforce d'être en première ligne quoi
que le premier réflexe de Bruno Le Maire
vous voyez c'est pas forcément de se
mettre en première ligne lui mais plutôt
de mettre la pression sur les assureurs
sur les banquiers pour dire bah faudrait
quand même être compréhensif avec les
commerçants qui ont été victimes
d'ailleurs il a priori était entendu au
moins par les assureurs puisque ils ont
allongé les délais pour faire des
déclarations de sinistre on passe de 5 à
30 jours donc le temps de faire le point
sur ce qui vous est arrivé il y a aussi
une autre mesure qui est de supprimer
les franchises pour entreprises et
particuliers bon ça c'est les assures
mais vous me direz le gouvernement
lui-même c'est bien beau de mettre la
pression mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait lui
artisan que en ce moment c'est pas
l'idéal de faire des chèques pour
soutenir puisque ça c'était début mai
quand Bruno Le Maire disait fini le quoi
qu'il en coûte ça je ne veux plus en
entendre parler donc du coup ben les
premiers gestes qu'il a annoncé c'est
plutôt des gestes mesurés au cas par cas
en l'écoute
aujourd'hui quand votre copain c'était
intégralement brûlé que c'est le travail
de toute une vie qui réduit en cendres
il faut que l'État soit à côté et qu'il
puisse y avoir des annulations de charge
sociale ou fiscales au cas par cas je le
redis pour les commerçants qui sont les
plus touchés au cas par cas donc
justement chacun devra déposer son
dossier mais soyons pas injuste parce
que il y a ce projet de loi qui sera
examiné à la fin du mois mais dès le 5
juillet le Matignon donc la première
ministre a pris en voyait une circulaire
à tous les préfets pour leur demander
d'activer toutes les dispositions qui
existent déjà dans la loi pour aller
plus vite accélérer les reconstructions
et voyez comment présenter cette
circulaire Olivier Véran qui est
porte-parole du gouvernement je vous
rappelle à la demande de la première
ministre une circulaire a été travaillée
dès cette nuit une circulaire donc qui a
été travaillé cette nuit par les
services des ministères concernés qui
permet de répondre probablement à 90%
voire 95% des situations bon vous avez
compris on attendra pas que le projet de
loi soit examiné pour entamer le
reconstruction pour essayer
d'aller plus vite mais alors du coup on
se dit mais à quoi sert ce projet de loi
qu'on attend à la fin du mois bon en
fait il vient de parler de 95% des
situations couvertes il en reste 5 % où
il y a peut-être des verrous juridiques
qui pourraient empêcher la
reconstruction et donc c'est l'objet du
projet de loi explication Olivier Vérand
lorsque vous parlez de reconstruire des
bâtiments qui ont été détruits et si
jamais vous ne les construisez pas à
l'identique si vous êtes en zone des
architectes des bâtiments de France par
exemple il y a des délais légaux qui
s'imposent avec des analyses nous
souhaitons pouvoir raccourcir tous ces
délais bon ben voilà place au débat sur
ce projet de loi d'urgence mais je suis
pas sûr qu'il y ait beaucoup d'opposants
à ce projet de loi c'est vrai
simplement croise les doigts pour que le
montant des dégâts n'augmente pas le 14
juillet comme certains le redoutent
peut-être que ça explique le silence du
président de la République à ce stade
j'ai commencé avec vous Philippe allauze
décrivez-nous un petit peu ce que vous
vivez on disait les chiffres tout à
l'heure les bureaux de tabac premier
visé dans du pays plus de 200 en
Île-de-France l'état des lieux globales
c'est quoi l'ampleur des sacs c'est des
devantures c'est l'ensemble
de ces impacts qui ont été faits dans
les bureaux de tabac qui est en train
d'être mesuré j'ai entendu que le
gouvernement faisait du cas par cas
notre profession s'engage à faire du cas
par cas pour tous les buralistes parce
que certains ont été que vandalisés il y
en a certains qui ont été brûlés il y en
a certains qui ont été pillés dans un
schéma très violent parce que c'est un
tsunami de violence que certains ont
vécu j'ai des établissements qui ont été
évités qui ont été visités 4 8 et dans
des amplitudes horaires assez larges
donc là c'est un traumatisme pour cette
indépendant vous pouvez bien comprendre
pour certains ils habitent au-dessus de
leur commerce on est vraiment dans le
schéma d'indépendance du commerçant
entre guillemets le vrai indépendant
entre guillemets nous n'avons pas de
franchise nous sommes bien sûr avec un
contrat de gérance avec l'État qui fait
que
on se pose des questions aussi sur le
sujet pourquoi nous avons été visés
aussi violemment et en aussi grand
nombre on porte des valeurs marchandes
qui sont très importantes alors je vais
pas revenir sur l'histoire du tabac et
de l'engagement de l'État et de notre
engagement nous en tant qu'indépendant
puisque nous avons un contrat de gérance
pour lequel nous avons le droit de
commercer sur le ce produit d'État le
schéma de la valeur qui est dans nos
établissements et en tout cas nos yeux
largement identifiés par toute tous ces
voyous et peut-être plus certaines mafia
donc j'ai beaucoup de mal à pouvoir dans
un premier temps pouvoir poser vraiment
le problème et ça sera vraiment
ferme on ferme pour combien de temps la
semaine complète est-ce que certains ont
ouvert des comment dirais-je nous avons
une pression économique qui est toujours
là avec schéma de prélèvement j'ai bien
entendu Monsieur Bruno Le Maire qui a
dit que il fallait que les assureurs se
rapprochent de nous ils l'ont fait nous
avons une chance dans notre métier de
buraliste c'est que nous avons une
mutuelle d'assurance qui s'appelle
amuseta fait complètement dédié au
buraliste mais elle ne couvre pas tous
les buralistes donc c'est oui il y a
d'autres bien sûr la concurrence est là
donc ça c'est un premier problème et
sous le schéma des banquiers aussi qui
j'ai encore appris que certains
n'avaient pas pu joindre leur banquier
donc il y a touchéma qui doit absolument
s'arrêter il faut faire une bulle
d'oxygène pour tous ces buralistes sinon
vous l'avez vu l'accélération est-ce
qu'il joue le jeu davantage les
assureurs vraiment au cas par cas on a
aussi essayé de faire une loi générale
13 et 14 juillet il y a un schéma
vraiment anxiogène pour certains on est
à peu près à 45% d'établissement qui ont
ouvert et je parle sous le schéma
français pour certains on a des remonté
l'information ou il y a un gros climat
anxiogène qui sont sur ces indépendants
qui ont subi qui ont pu rouvrir de
briques et de broc bien souvent aussi
avec ses valeurs qu'il a fallu
réachalandée puisque notre métier fait
qu'on n'est jamais propriétaire de notre
stock la valeur de contrat comporte avec
l'État qu'est-ce que vous attendez alors
justement des pouvoirs publics vraiment
qu'on arrive à déconnecter à peu près
tous les buralistes qui ont été impactés
sous le schéma bancaire avec tous les
prélèvements qui sont
l'usuels de tout commerçant mais il faut
impérativement les mettre sous oxygène
en tout cas débrancher tous ces
prélèvements et faire du cas par cas
pour vraiment essayer de sauver notre
maillage c'est un de nos engagements
nous sommes au travers de notre
organisation professionnelle on a un
action avec les douanes et on essaie de
mailler le terrain avec les douanes en
bonne corrélation et j'ai une grande
crainte pour notre maillage bon on va on
va y revenir je commence par les acteurs
de terrain on va dire plus locaux
que notamment Monsieur le Maire
Jean-Philippe du goinclément faites-nous
un peu l'inventaire de ce qui s'est
passé chez vous
côté public côté privé chez moi j'étais
relativement épargné on a eu deux nuits
agitées avec des tirs de mortier avec
des dégradations sur du mobilier
urbain des feux de poubelle mais pas de
grands dégâts sur des équipements
publics ou des commerces par contre on a
énormément de communes et on le voit sur
l'association des merdes de France qui
ont été frappés extrêmement durement à
répétition et avec des commerçants ce
que vous disiez pour les buralistes on
le retrouve sur des concessions
automobiles qui ont été pillées avec des
véhicules concert vides voitures bélier
d'autres qui ont été purement et
simplement incendiés avec des banques
etc et puis énormément d'équipements
publics touchés les postes peu de police
municipale ça a été des cibles c'est
plusieurs dizaines en France qui ont été
attaqués certains détruits tout ce qui
est les dispositifs de vidéoprotection
une commune comme Aulnay-sous-Bois c'est
une cinquantaine de caméras qui ont été
détruites avec des attaques aux
bulldozer donc il y a une violence
extrêmement fort deux bandes organisées
avec une volonté majeure de détruire et
le sujet qui va se poser aujourd'hui
pour les collectivités c'est d'assurer
une continuité de service public de
remettre en état très très vite alors
que ce soit on a un petit peu une chance
dans le malheur c'est qu'on arrive en
période estivale et que en période
estivale on a beaucoup de services qui
fonctionnent au ralenti la question des
écoles notamment
fonctionnent totalement ralenti ça nous
laisse un petit peu de temps on aimer
quels sont les guichets c'est d'abord sa
collectivité ça mérit qui développe sur
ses fonds
en demandant de manière immédiate des
avances sur des sommes estimées pour
pouvoir rembourser donc ça c'est ce que
disait Bruno Le Maire c'est à quelle
vitesse les assurances effectivement des
blocs des avances et éventuellement des
avances pour pouvoir assurer une
continuité de service bâtiment public
également assuré quelle que soit privé
publique les écoles sont assurées etc
plusieurs mois ou plusieurs années si on
est sur une destruction totale un centre
de loisirs si vous avez besoin de
maintenir un service ça va être des
locations d'Algeco pour pouvoir arriver
à le faire fonctionner et donc c'est des
dépenses immédiates donc la première
chose c'est c'est des blocages d'avance
de fond pour les collectivités la
deuxième chose c'est vous redéploiements
budgétaires ont fonctionnent pour les
communes en annuité budgétaire donc la
réalité c'est que gérer des dépenses
immédiates c'est des choses qui peuvent
être faites en déploiement budgétaire
mais il y a bien un moment où il va
falloir les régulariser d'ici à la fin
de l'année ou vous n'avez pas forcément
de recette supplémentaire et donc là
c'est important dans les mois qui
viennent pas forcément dans la semaine
mais en tout cas d'ici à septembre
d'avoir des déblocages des assurances
d'avoir des aides potentiellement
d'autres collectivités pour l'instant
l'État ne s'est pas positionné dessus ça
viendra peut-être la région
Île-de-France
d'urgence pour les commerçants et pour
les collectivités sous forme d'avance
remboursable d'ailleurs sur les
collectivités des départements pense à
l'Essonne sont en train de déployer des
moyens notamment en termes de bâtiments
provisoire ou d'Algeco qui peuvent
servir pour venir éviter qu'on ait une
rupture de chaîne sur la continuité du
service public mais en fait ce qui est
très important c'est de déployer des
fonds d'urgence la réalité c'est que les
assurances à terme vont être amenés à
rembourser j'espère bien mais comment
est-ce qu'on passe le gap alors ça c'est
une question importante on a bien
compris qu'au fond voilà ce projet de
loi il est technique et il fait en sorte
qu'on accélère en facilitant en
simplifiant toutes les procédures mais
la question c'est l'argent c'est qui
paye quand qui paye tout de suite est-ce
que il y a pas besoin d'un fonds
d'urgence de l'État tout de suite pour
venir rassurer les mers ne pas laisser
le financement aux régions alors en fait
ça vient d'être dit le enfin le
principal acteur enfin en tout cas le
principal le l'acteur qui vient auquel
on prend son premier c'est l'assureur
qui assure à la fois les commerces ceux
qui ont été très lourdement impactés et
qui est qui assure les bâtiments publics
c'est évidemment
absolument donc ça il faut vraiment
regarder parce qu'il y a une multitude
de contrats une multitude d'assureurs
sur mutualise aussi d'assurance enfin
voilà selon on peut leur faire confiance
aux assureurs pour jouer le jeu et
pareil situation on va le voir sur le
sur le terrain et je pense qu'il faut
d'abord il pense que la immense majorité
des maires n'ont déjà fait d'abord
porter plainte pour que l'enquête est
lieux plus rapidement possible
déclaration d'assureur pour qu'il puisse
engager tout de suite les démarches
qu'un expert qui puisse constater
effectivement l'ampleur des dégâts
est-ce qu'il faut une reconstruction
totale ou est-ce qu'il faut donc là il y
a vraiment ça on va on va le regarder
moi j'ai déjà effectivement une vitrine
à Montceau-les-Mines qui a été assez
clairement endommagée l'assureur alors
parce qu'il y avait une bonne
sinistralité c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y
avait pas eu de sinistre au cours des
années précédentes il semblerait qu'il
prend en charge donc là effectivement il
faut en cas par cas ça c'est vraiment le
premier acteur principal et ensuite il y
a effectivement la question de du
financement public mais celui-là il va
s'inscrire dans dans le cadre accéléré
et effectivement moi je souhaite que
l'on puisse voter très largement ce
texte parce qu'avec le débat sur le
financement vous l'aurez dans
l'hémicycle même si les reporté au
budget de la rentrée dans dans un
certain nombre de disposition on va
assouplir pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
financer jusqu'à 100% par subvention de
pour subvention publique jusqu'à
actuellement c'était jusqu'à 80% c'est
un peu technique mais grosso modo il
fallait trouver 20% de financement
au-delà on va pouvoir en fait utiliser
tous les leviers maximum mais mais un
président public qui se finance à la
fois par l'État mais aussi par les
régions les départements les communautés
d'agglomération les communistes les
travaux sont en tout cas ce qui est
torciste qui est le gymnase qui a été
plus gravement ménagé c'est endommagée
pardon qui est une commune de 1500
habitants à côté du Creusot l'assureur
est passé il y a quelques jours ils vont
engager les choses mais je pense que
l'enjeu c'est d'aller plus vite possible
à la fois pour montrer que l'État et
toutes les puissances publiques sont au
côté de tous les acteurs qui ont subi
gravement que ce soit des acteurs privés
comme les acteurs publics mais aussi je
pense qu'à un enjeu notamment je pense
aux écoles certes on a les vacances mais
l'école reprendra dans deux mois et je
pense que montrer qu'on a fait le
maximum pour pouvoir soit remettre les
enfants dans un établissement viable ou
le cas échéant en établissement de
remplacement
trois étapes je pense que c'est dégradé
mais il y a que 10 établissements il
faut le dire c'est quand même une très
grosse petite minorité qui ne pourront
pas accueillir les les élèves à la
rentrée qui ont été trop gravement
dommage et détruit Nanterre
racontez-nous est-ce que Nanterre se
remet ou pas je pense un peu réellement
comme toutes les villes qui ont été
impactées lors de cette semaine un peu
plus difficilement pour Nanterre parce
que forcément c'est là qu'a eu lieu la
mort de Naël mais
paradoxalement il y a eu très peu
d'équipements publics qui ont été touché
à Nanterre par exemple sur le quartier
Pablo Picasso qui a été le plus visible
où il y a eu le plus de voitures brûlées
aucun équipement public n'a été brûlé il
y a une école qui a été endommagée il y
a un centre un centre de loisirs un
centre social qui a été complètement
incendié mais voilà au final très peu
d'équipements publics beaucoup de
voitures beaucoup de d'abris de bus
beaucoup de enfin voilà vraiment avec
une chose
enfin les banques commerciales mais très
peu aussi également pas tant que ça
finalement
c'est déjà trop je minimise pas du tout
mais ce que je veux dire que
paradoxalement par rapport au fait que
ça soit partie de Nanterre je pense que
la colère qui s'est exprimée à ce
moment-là et c'est pour ça que moi je
distingue vraiment on parlait tout à
l'heure de pillage pour moi ce qui s'est
exprimé cette semaine là c'est pas la
même chose partout je pense qu'il faut
vraiment distinguer les choses il y a
une colère qui s'exprime au moment de la
mort de Naël ou les gens sont sortis
brûler des voitures casser des abris de
bus en bas de chez eux et puis dans un
deuxième temps pour moi c'est quelque
chose de très différent il y a eu des
pillages il y a eu des magasins qui ont
été saccagés des bureaux de tabac
d'autres établissements ce deuxième
temps vous le comprenez comment
je pourrais pas vous le dire moi je suis
pas sociologue il faudrait vraiment que
des sociologues se penchent sur ce qui
s'est passé ces jours là mais c'est sûr
que c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
quand même quand on voit qu'il y en a
qui ont peut-être profiter de la
situation pour aller piller des magasins
et c'était organisé comme ça était dit
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
qu'une colère qui s'est exprimée dans
les deux premiers jours au moment où on
a brûlé des voitures on a et voilà on
s'est attaqué pour certaines villes aux
équipements publics les plus à proximité
de chez soi alors on va regarder en
images comment s'opère sur le terrain
cette reconstruction m'a été Frémont et
Camille sous haut se sont rendus à
Sannois notamment dans le Val-d'Oise
visite guidée en compagnie du maire mais
pas seulement un restaurateur un peu
plus loin également reportage
moi à 17 km
Sannois à 17 km de Paris
bonjour
et bien écoutez jeudi matin il y a une
dizaine de jours
et bien il y a des émotiers qui sont
arrivés en nombre ils étaient une bonne
trentaine voilà
merci
qu'avant il y avait une belle porte
vitrée qui s'ouvrait automatiquement
c'est à complètement disparu et
aujourd'hui on a mis une charpente en
bois avec des tôles de en métal pour
protéger la mairie et j'espère que
bientôt on va rénover tout ça et réparer
tout ça le coup des dégâts est
aujourd'hui évalué par la mairie à 60000
euros car le centre culturel a également
été touché voilà
et les dégâts réparer maintenant
de la ville sont des gens exceptionnels
en attendant des aides la mairie a
avancé l'argent pour réparer
à 20 km de sa noix Cergy ici les dégâts
sont plus imposants une maison de
quartier vandalisée le bureau de police
municipale deux aires de jeux et une
partie de la voirie ont été attaqués si
on prend la totalité je pense qu'on va
approcher très rapidement le million
d'euros est-ce qu'on a les moyens de le
faire aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que
non et c'est pour ça qu'on attend
véritablement à ce que l'État nous
accompagne fortement dans la
reconstruction il faut aller vite les
particuliers sont aussi touchés à
Nanterre ce restaurateur a perdu sa
terrasse
[Musique]
avec des numéros de table de plan de
table pour lui la facture s'élève à 70
000 euros je t'ai contacté par la
Chambre de commerce ils ont pas d'aide
officiel d'état en fait mais qui doit
payer pour cette reconstruction retour à
sa noix ou le maire a bien une idée
mettre à contribution les émeutiers
techniquement ils seront peut-être pas
capables de ils peuvent quand même
accompagner
vous savez les artisans ils ont à côté
de ce qu'on appelle les arpètes les
apprentis peuvent très bien porter les
caisses donner l'outil contribuer par un
effort c'est même pas un effort c'est un
dur en fait un dû à la République
le Marguerite on n'est pas sur le
financier là on est sur participer à la
reconstruction pour ces jeunes notamment
les plus jeunes mineurs qui ont qui ont
participé à ces violences on entend
cette petite musique dans une partie de
la classe politique montée il faut au
fond qu'il participe même si c'est
symbolique peut-être des travaux
d'intérêt général qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez mais moi je pense que déjà il
faut éviter d'envoyer le message que peu
importe que ce soit l'état au canon en
tout cas que la politique de chèque est
ouverte évidemment il faut trouver des
financements non mais là sur le maire là
c'est très différent de ma question en
terme de message donc je pense que c'est
important de montrer que c'est qu'il y a
un coût et que ce n'est pas neutre et
j'entends ce message je pense que c'est
déjà ça doit venir de la justice
puisqu'il y a eu toutes les on peut
condamner à des travaux
je pense que c'est une assez bonne
alternative on voit là qu'on si en plus
les travaux d'intérêt général peuvent se
retrouver les moyens de le faire ça cet
été rapidement ou pas très concrètement
parce que sur le papier
finalement spécialiste pour savoir si on
pourrait tout de suite les mettre sur
les chantiers il faudrait pouvoir les
faire embaucher j'imagine que peut-être
qu'on apprenti comme ça j'en sais rien
il faut en tout cas ça me paraît être
une idée plutôt saine si ces travaux
d'intérêt généraux peuvent très
concrètement s'appliquer effectivement
sur sur ce type d'idée mais je pense
qu'effectivement après il faut qu'on
sait sur qu'on est la globalité du
financement pour tout pour repartir on
entend et il le dit évidemment je pense
que évidemment on a ces étages
l'assurance suffira pas on entend mais
il faut évidemment on a une heure
heureusement et moi je salue d'ailleurs
tous les agents municipaux il y en avait
beaucoup à Montceau-les-Mines en ma
circonscription il y avait beaucoup
ailleurs qui ont évité que en étant très
présent sur le terrain dans toutes les
nuits évitez que cette folie
destructrice parce que c'est ça dont il
s'agit et il y a sans doute des causes
qui sont très multiples et c'est tous
les destructrices puissent enfin faire
en sorte des dégâts encore plus
importants que ce qu'on a que ce que ce
qu'on a obtenu ce qu'on a vu donc
évidemment il faut qu'on ait à la fin et
je pense que l'enjeu c'est que chaque
maire chaque chef d'entreprise tous ceux
qui ont été impactés soient très
concrètement accompagnés qui puisse
trouver une oreille attentive soit par
les fédérations soit par les Chambres de
commerce soit par les associations
d'élus soit par leur députés quel qu'il
on sent qu'il y a quand même pas mal
d'inquiétudes mais je pense qu'il faut
que c'est énormément d'inquiétudes à
répondre peut-être sur cette question là
qui est la question parle beaucoup
d'autorité la sanction doit être
comprise si ces jeunes qui ont participé
à ces violences pas tous évidemment mais
se retrouver dans des travaux d'intérêt
généraux dans les lieux qu'ils ont
peut-être contribué à endommager voire
voir pire je pense aux écoles en
particulier qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors leur école parfois même alors je
vais juste revenir un tout petit peu en
arrière je pense qu'effectivement le
chèque c'est pas ça qui réglera tout je
pense que la première étape c'est
d'abord de prendre conscience que ce qui
s'est passé est en lien aussi avec un
problème profond qui traverse et nos
villes populaires et parfois certaines
villes qui sont dans la ruralité qui ont
aussi brûlé il y a pas que des villes de
grande ville il y a aussi des
territoires où il y a un sentiment
d'éclassement peu de service public
parfois pas de transport des
ségrégations territoriales qui existent
aussi et un rapport à la police qui
n'est pas évident et je pense
aujourd'hui que sortir le chèque pour
moi c'est pas toute la solution il faut
aider les collectivités il faut les
entreprises bien évidemment mais je
pense qu'il faut prendre conscience
aussi qu'il y a une fracture qu'il faut
la réparer et que si on ne le fait pas
et bien comme ce qu'on a vécu en 2005 on
le vit en 2003 on le vivra peut-être
encore dans quelques années donc vous
avez beaucoup travaillé sur les
questions je pense que il faut entendre
mais cette idée là parce que peut-être
Michel Goya vous avez ça existe enfin je
veux dire
ça alors ça existe aujourd'hui la
difficulté des tiges moi j'ai été
longtemps sur la prévention d'abord il
faut faire il faut mettre en place un
partenaire avec la justice surtout pour
les mineurs ça prend un peu de temps
ensuite il faut pouvoir avoir des
tuteurs qui accueillent les tiges dans
leur collectivité ça peut être des
bailleurs ça peut être des entreprises
ça peut être ça peut être plein de
dispositifs y compris des collectivités
il faut des tuteurs dans les services
pour accueillir l'enjeu n'est pas
suffisant pour les trouver les
tutoralités et puis surtout il faut que
le tige ait lieu très rapidement après
le après la prononciation pas la peine
si on a un tige deux ans après avoir en
général
il faut comprendre pour quoi on fait un
tige sinon ça n'a aucun intérêt et vous
pensez que c'est possible de faire ça
tout de suite maintenant ou c'est c'est
impossible ça prendrait je peux vous
dire que je l'avais je l'avais beaucoup
porté au moment où j'étais élu et on a
difficilement réussi à accueillir une
dizaine de tiges parce que il faut des
tuteurs ça prend du temps il faut des
conventions donc si on arrive à le faire
c'est très bien parce que je pense que
c'est que vous auriez pas favorable de
comprendre effectivement un compromis à
trouver la j'entends que voilà il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de groupes différents
qui politiques je ne sais pas si c'est
faisable qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
Michel coyen sur le principe oui ça
paraît effectivement une bonne idée mais
qui comme souvent ce but sur des
multitudes de contraintes
administratives en particulier comme
beaucoup de choses dans notre pays
malheureusement qui qui freine qui
freine souvent l'action qui freine les
bonnes idées et on aurait les moyens
votre avis très rapidement puisqu'on est
sur de l'inédit et de l'urgence qui
tombe qui tombe vite et tombe de manière
réelle et efficiente après accueillir
dans une commune le tige ça veut dire
qu'il faut que la personne soit
retrouvée soit condamnée qu'elle soit
condamnée rapidement que la commune est
déjà passée des accords pour pouvoir le
faire moi c'est le cas sur ma commune
mais faut avoir les accords et puis quel
type de dégâts si vous êtes sur un
bâtiment comme celui qu'on voit qui
était totalement détruit c'est pas un
tige sur un mineur de 14-15 diffusant
pour pouvoir faire quelque chose il y a
une rue oui bien sûr on est sur des
spécial
le problème c'est véritablement qu'on
retrouve les personnes et qui est des
sanctions rapides et efficientes bon
alors on va écouter Marine Le Pen à
présent qui elle a une autre proposition
à faire écoutez là elle elle était au
micro déjà montagaba cet après-midi au 4
quoi
qui va payer parce que si c'est encore
les contribuables qu'ils soient locaux
ou au niveau national qui paye pour les
dégradations qui sont commises c'est un
supportable aux Français insupportable
il faut maintenant prendre des
dispositions et nous allons voir si le
gouvernement s'avance sur ce sujet pour
que ce soit les pilleurs
de manière très claire et si ce sont des
mineurs que ce soit leurs parents
ils paieront toute leur vie et bien ils
paieront toute leur vie ça leur passera
l'envie d'aller détruire le bien commun
Philippe vous allez me dire je fais pas
de politique mais est-ce que cette
petite musique chez les buralistes en
colère vous l'entendez monter aussi
attention le contribuable c'est encore
lui qui à la fin va payer c'est encore
lui encore lui qui va payer à la fin il
y a avec cette population on a pu voir
qu'il y avait des mineurs qui avaient
fait ce schéma d'émeutes cet effet de
masse puisque vous avez dit il y a eu
deux temps et je reprends les propos de
Madame dans le fait ou Nanterre a pas
été touché je sais que on a les points
d'impact nous on a fait un ordre de
bataille dans les points d'impact qui
sont déclarés dans les jours après donc
il y a schéma et il y a aussi on ne
parle plus à cette population alors
mineur ou peut-être autre parce que les
raisons ont pris trop de place
et ça ça a été un phénomène de bataille
je crois qu'on a un militaire et je
pense que la communication c'est la base
pour pouvoir et ça a été ça a été un
flux moi on a on est vraiment très
impacté nous en tant qu'indépendant
j'entends les élus j'entends je fais que
du cas par cas maintenant nous on ne
pourra pas s'en sortir si on ne fait pas
du cas par cas je peux entendre les
assureurs pour certains beaucoup se sont
engagés les banquiers comme je l'ai dit
au début beaucoup ce sont engagés il y
en a encore certains qui ne sont pas là
et on le voit tous les jours on ne fera
que du cas par cas pour nous
j'arrête
pourquoi je vais rouvrir je suis un
commerce de proximité on s'était engagé
on était dans un phénomène nous les
buralistes à devenir un commerce de
proximité nous devenions un schéma de
France service puisque nous apportons la
population juste pour savoir nous sommes
à devenir alors malheureusement avec
tout à devenir le premier réseau
bancaire d'ouverture de compte en France
est-ce que vous le savez non vous me la
prenez donc voilà on est vraiment dans
un service
une sanction une sanction qui peut être
financière est-ce que c'est directement
avec des avec des prestations à la
source ou pas parce que c'est est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est la première
connerie
la question qui nous est posée moi il se
trouve une circonscription assez divers
et je me suis vas-y je me suis promis
dans la coach et où il y a heureusement
pas eu ces villages tous ça se passe
plutôt bien et ils m'ont tous dit mais
monsieur le député qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire pour que ça ne recommence
pas en fait c'est ça la question donc
elle va être multiple évidemment il faut
être très ferme très ferme parce que
c'est ce qui s'est passé audio
que son silence commence à devenir un
peu long enfin en tout cas je crois
qu'il a reçu assez vite les mères en
tout cas
dans 200 je crois un peu plus de deux
entre 200 et 300 sont allés au palais
d'Elysées des maires de grandes communes
de petites communes de moyenne donc on
peut pas dire qu'il se soit pas et en
plus à son initiative et c'est du
gouvernement il y a un projet de loi qui
arrive très vite et j'espère qu'on aura
une unité au Parlement pour le pour le
voter donc encore une fois je pense
qu'il faut séquence c'est d'abord tout
de suite stopper les violences je vous
espérez qu'elles sont derrière nous
ensuite c'est trop construction rapide
cette sanction est d'être effectivement
encore une fois mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et ensuite tu
auras évidemment un bilan attiré de ce
qui chaque chose au fond de teint vous
voterez le projet de loi juste pour
savoir là-dessus vous pouvez nous dire
déjà qu'il y a une majorité dans cette
nouvelle Assemblée on vient à peine
d'avoir le texte donc on va regarder
dans le détail effectivement ce qui est
proposé mais si c'est trois articles
c'est très court 4e va disparaître et
95% des situations sont réglées déjà
sans la loi donc a priori il y a une
majorité là-dessus voilà bah oui mais je
le redis comme ça a été évoqué ça ne
suffira pas ça ne suffira pas c'est
évident que vous l'avez en profondeur ce
qui ne va pas en fait on voulait faire
le point justement avec les acteurs de
terrain sur les différents guichets des
financements s'arrête là merci beaucoup
d'être venu débattre sur LCP vous restez
avec moi Michel Goya dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir on se délocalise à
Vilnius avec Richard Werly vous le voyez
à droite pour le sommet de l'OTAN carton
rouge de Bertrand Perrier contre la
chanteuse Higelin et puis Elsa quel est
le thème de Bourbon Express ce soir je
vous parle des députés de la majorité
qui veulent sanctionner les députés de
la nupes pas pour leur comportement dans
l'assemblée mais à l'extérieur je vous
explique à tout à l'heure les amis allez
on va parler de l'Ukraine et de la
guerre qui a 500 jours un peu plus même
aujourd'hui votre livre l'ours et le
renard chez Perrin revient sur cette
guerre sur l'armée ukrainienne qui a
finalement résisté mais qui a subi aussi
beaucoup de pertes une guerre de
position plus une guerre de mouvement
vous allez nous expliquer pourquoi c'est
votre lecture en tout cas premier champ
de bataille beaucoup plus transparent
que les précédents regardez c'est dans
l'invitation d'Hélène Bonduelle on en
parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Michel Goya c'est
qu'au moment où l'OTAN réunit pendant
deux jours à Vilnius s'apprête à
réévaluer l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine
vous signez un récit unique sur cette
guerre autour d'un dialogue minutieux
avec l'historien Jean Lopez vous publiez
l'ours et le renard histoire immédiate
de la guerre en Ukraine
pendant huit mois vous avez échangé vos
impressions vos analyses sur cette
guerre et un premier constat assumer
l'aveuglement
occidental le vôtre aussi sur cette
décision incongrue de la Russie
d'attaquer l'Ukraine il y a toujours de
bonne guerre de montrer ses muscles pour
essayer d'obtenir un résultat politique
sans faire la guerre on a pensé qu'on
était dans le scénario on s'est trompé
une bonne stratégie elle doit associer
un objectif réaliste et des moyens
adaptés et là très clairement il
manquait l'un et l'autre à la Russie
Michel Goya ancien officier des troupes
de marine vous êtes historiens
spécialiste de la guerre auteur d'une
quinzaine d'ouvrages sur le sujet
que s'est-il réellement passé dans le
don-basse à carquif sur les rives de la
Mer Noire ou dans l'attaque des deux
gazeux duc qu'en est-il de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne tant
annoncé après plus de 500 jours de
combat chacun campe sur ses positions
Poutine ne veut rien lâcher quand elle
inscrivez tout reprendre
[Musique]
alors Michel Goya nous avons une
question
au moment où nous franchissons un
nouveau cap dans l'aide militaire
l'Ukraine a-t-elle les moyens matériels
et stratégiques de gagner la guerre
[Musique]
oui oui mais il faudrait d'abord savoir
ce que signifie gagner la guerre
reprendre le don-basse reprendre même la
Crimée ce scénario là est-ce que il est
possible ça c'est l'objectif
effectivement c'est l'objectif
stratégique affiché actuellement par
l'Ukraine n'a pas toujours été le cas
initialement au début du conflit au
début de l'invasion en tout cas le
premier objectif c'était simplement
survivre puis ensuite éventuellement
repousser les Russes sur la ligne de
départ sur les déjà suffi pour peut-être
donc on en est plus là maintenant
ukrainien veulent tout récupérer
sans pour l'instant c'est encore
possible c'est encore possible oui c'est
encore possible et ce qui va se passer
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent seront sans doute déterminants
pour savoir si réellement c'est possible
alors on va regarder la carte c'est
celle du conflit aujourd'hui la bits
cric de Poutine n'a pas eu lieu l'armée
russe s'est repliée sur le don de base
mais a repris baroute et les Ukrainiens
ont repris une bonne partie du Nord et
une partie du Sud du don de base on va
vous connaissez ça mieux que moi
notamment Carson pourquoi vous dites
finalement quand on voit quand même des
mouvements que c'est une guerre de
position parce que il y a eu mes fiction
énormément de mouvements pendant le
premier mois de guerre il y a eu toute
l'invasion du sud du pays par les Russes
qui a été assez facile c'est leur grande
victoire en réalité toutes les provinces
de Carson et une partie de la province
de saporja dans le Nord cette tentative
en revanche a complètement échoué autour
de Kiev il y a une immense bataille
toute cette bataille oui enfin de car
kiffe jusqu'à Kiev c'est quasiment tout
le nord de la France quoi dans le terme
en dimension cette bataille a été perdue
par les Russes ils ont été obligés de se
replier et à partir du mois d'avril on
s'aperçoit que les choses se sont fixées
et on est cette guerre de mouvement avec
beaucoup de mouvements effectivement
c'est transformé en gare de position ce
qui en fait nous-même assez classique en
réalité les guerres modernes sont très
meurtrières et si on s'impose pas enfin
s'il y a un camp qui ne s'impose pas
tout de suite ce qui arrive assez
fréquemment quelques semaines quelques
mois cette guerre a tendance à se
prolonger tout le monde s'en tait on se
fortifie et ça devient de garde position
qui est durer des années alors on va
parler des deux armées force et
faiblesses de l'armée russe de Poutine
vous parlez d'une armée soviétique
classique complètement surestimé par le
chef du Kremlin
pas que par le chef du Kremlin mais vous
savez c'est très difficile de savoir
comment va se comporter une armée
lorsque commence une guerre
c'est comme si vous allez estimer quel
sera le résultat d'un match de foot
alors que vous ayez les équipes n'ont
pas le droit de jouer avant donc vous
dites voilà dans deux ans il s'est deux
équipes vont jouer l'une contre l'autre
surestimé par tout le monde en fait et
donc bon oui c'est assez classique aussi
les Russes sont quand même aussi assez
forts pour présenter toujours une enfin
ses inventeur du concept de village
Potemkine donc toujours présenté une
face brillante ou puissante et puis
derrière c'est souvent plus
comment dire c'est beaucoup moins
moins brillant justement et là oui c'est
cette armée était
beaucoup de progrès c'est une armée
puissante c'est une force complète
c'est le plus grand arme enfin la plus
grande force nucléaire du monde en terme
le nombre de têtes nucléaires c'est une
aviation puissante c'est une armée qui
va dans l'espace c'est
etc mais mais c'est un peu c'était
effectivement un peu une armée potable
qui ne c'est une armée qui a réussi
aussi un certain nombre de choses la
guerre
2014-2015 dans lequel est intervenue
cette terre merus a été une victoire
finalement pour eux l'intervention en
Syrie militairement c'est plutôt c'était
plutôt bien fait donc on avait vraiment
cette impression d'une armée voilà
vraiment puissante plus puissante en
tout cas que celle de l'Ukraine qui
donnait plutôt des indices initialement
des indices plutôt contraire
aujourd'hui cette armée là elle peut se
passer des 26 000 hommes de Wagner
depuis le putch manqué est-ce qu'elle
peut en l'état faire sans ces hommes qui
sont partis depuis cette mutine riz
avortée alors 26000 sur il doit y avoir
36000 combattants russes et séparatistes
en Ukraine donc quantitativement c'est
pas pas très important mais en même
temps c'est malgré tout on va dire
c'était une troupe d'élite une troupe
forte incontestablement dont il faut
rappeler que c'était pas forcément le
premier métier Wagner c'est normalement
été inventé pour aller justement là où
il ne veut pas on ne veut pas envoyer
l'armée russe pour maintenir les choses
dans ce qu'on appelle du déniplosible
dire bah c'est Wagner c'est pas nous etc
donc particulièrement dans le théâtre
extérieur en Syrie d'abord complètement
se retrouver voilà cette armée parce
qu'il y a il fallait faire feu de tout
bois on a été utilisé dans dans cette
guerre et puis et puis elle est devenue
un monstre et c'est un petit peu il peut
faire ça parce que on sent que l'onde de
choc depuis cette mutinerie alors
certains discours d'état ou tentatives
de coup d'État ou de elle est
encore là elle se propage encore même si
n'est plus là même si on ne sait plus où
il est exactement on voit bien que la
rancoeur des nationalistes et là ceux
qui critiquent encore soyou le ministre
de la Défense qui disent au fond cette
fameuse opération spéciale on la défense
mais on l'a fait mal et ça c'est encore
en Russie et ça ça fait mal non oui bien
sûr dans une heure fin d'abord ce ne
sont pas les armées qui feront les
guerres ce sont les nations la force
d'une nation c'est effectivement c'est
son armée qui est devant l'avant mais
aussi toute l'arrière l'arrière de la
société et le fonctionnement de l'État
des deux côtés de côté craignant on a
une nation en arme qui est très
déterminée qui est solide et du côté
russe c'est un peu plus compliqué on a
beaucoup moins impliqué la nationalité
dans la dans cette guerre il y a pas eu
de mobilisation générale comme il y a eu
en Ukraine en partie parce que
certainement le pouvoir se méfie
justement peu de sa propre société
plus profonde mais se méfie aussi de ces
organes de sécurité c'est-à-dire que la
société enfin l'État russe est devenu il
n'y a plus de monopole de l'emploi la
force légitime mais plutôt une oligopole
avec tout un comment dire l'oligarchie
de la société l'oligarchie économique a
donné naissance aussi à une oligarchie
de sécurité avec des champs des gens qui
peuvent aussi menacer directement le
pouvoir force et faiblesses de l'armée
ukrainienne comment vous jugez cette
contre-offensive
ukrainienne qui est allée jusque en
territoire russe ça a été très
symbolique même si c'est symbolique
est-ce que est-ce qu'elle est efficace
cette contre-offensive aujourd'hui où là
il s'agit d'avancer alors cet armée
ukrainienne est devenue la première
armée d'Europe l'armée la plus puissante
d'Europe incontestablement et si un jour
l'Ukraine rentrait dans l'OTAN ce serait
or les États-Unis ce serait l'armée la
plus puissante européenne dans cette
organisation à cause de nos de nos aides
à nos soutiens militaires ou ces hommes
les Ukrainiens
une détermination une mobilisation
humaine qui est considérable avec
d'ailleurs même d'un point de vue
militaire on voit toute la différence
entre une armée russe qui reste quand
même une armée de professionnels
volontaires qui est un peu à part coupé
un peu du reste de la nation et cette
armée ukrainienne ou il y a une
multitude de gens qui sont venus de
volontaires de mobiliser qui sont venus
des civils qui sont venus avec leur
vision des choses leur rapport leur
rapport technique etc ça a transformé
aujourd'hui pour véritablement la gagner
cette contre-offensive parce qu'on a
beaucoup livré malgré tout ça après du
temps il y a eu des paliers mais ça y
est on est plus au char là on est aux
avions de chasse F16 les Américains vont
les livrer il y a des missiles français
aussi qu'est-ce qui manque encore des
obus voilà pour parler simplement
actuellement c'est à dire que on est on
l'a dit dans une guerre de position
c'est à dire que là les
Ukrainiens pour atteindre leur objectif
dont on parle au départ
libérer tout le territoire en superficie
ce qui reste à libérer l'équivalent en
France de la superficie de l'Occitanie
plus la région Provence
et pour ça il faut qu'ils obtiennent des
grandes victoires il faut qu'ils cassent
le front il faut qu'ils aillent loin qui
donne des grands coups à cette armée
russe et problème c'est que l'armée
russe pour l'instant sur la défensive
les Russes mènent au score d'une
certaine façon si la guerre s'arrêtait
aujourd'hui il pourrait dire écoutez
voilà nous on a gagné on a libéré entre
guillemets un certain nombre de
territoires etc et donc il faut les
Ukrainiens doivent passer à l'offensive
mais pour passer l'offensive et réussir
cette bataille très difficile dans des
faces à des positions retranchées très
retranchées la réalité il faut il faut
beaucoup de puissance de feu il faut
écraser cette défense pour pouvoir et
pour pouvoir pénétrer à l'intérieur il y
a pas de 36 solutions les livraisons il
faut il faut je voudrais qu'on parle un
peu de l'actualité c'est aussi Erdogan
l'actualité sur l'Ukraine qui a joué un
on le sait très ambigu sur ce conflit
mais il a autorisé Zelenski à revenir de
Turquie avec des combats d'Azov les
fameux combattants de cette usine à
sauvetale
ukrainien n'est plus durs il est pour
vous ça y est du côté de Kiev ou il a
trahi Poutine ou ça reste un jeu
d'équilibre
Erdogan et du côté d'ergogans voilà
c'est une manière un jeu très
personnelle
où il essaie de gagner un peu sur
ma position d'hommes indispensable de
tous les camps et maintient des faits au
feu dans tous les camps il maintient le
contact avec la Russie quand tu es
simplement il faut quand même pas
oublier aussi au passage que la Turquie
c'est le pays de l'OTAN qui est en
contact militaire avec la Russie
c'est-à-dire en Syrie il y a des
affrontements avec entre turcs et russes
régulièrement et d'ailleurs ce qui se
passe actuellement n'est peut-être pas
étranger à des événements qu'on n'entend
pas parlé mais qui ont lieu en Syrie
entre turcs et russes donc là j'ai pas
compris il y a eu des combats des
combats il y a eu un certain nombre de
gens tur qui ont été tués je crois par
des par des Russes
donc on comprend mieux la Turquie
pour le moment oui pour le moment il
donne des signes à l'Ukraine il donne
des signes à l'OTAN et il accepte la
comment dire l'entrée de la Suède dans
le temps puisqu'il s'est décisions à
l'unanimité mais certainement en échange
de beaucoup de choses puissant la
position sur la politique kurde en
Turquie par exemple les les opposants
Erdogan voilà qui sont qui vont sortir
de Suède en contrepartie de son
intégration tout petit mot pour terminer
Michel Goya parce qu'on va partir
justement à Vilnius avec Richard Werny
faire l'histoire immédiate d'un conflit
c'est toujours un peu périlleux mais
vous expliquer bien que cette fois-ci
les sources sont très différentes elles
sont très nombreuses et que on voit le
champ de bataille grâce notamment aux
moyens satellitaires grâce au téléphone
portable qui devient une arme de guerre
ça change tout
ça change beaucoup de choses c'est pas
complètement nouveau mais ça change
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
effectivement on a beaucoup
d'informations dites ouvertes ce qui
permet à n'importe qui en réalité de de
faire des analyses alors ce que le plus
value de Jean Jean Lopez ou moi-même
c'est certaines expertises moi je fais
de l'analyse des conflits depuis 19 ans
en réalité donc c'est un peu mon métier
de d'analyser les choses avec mon
savoir-faire militaire mais la limite
n'importe qui peut faire faire ce
travail pour peu qu'ils prennent le
temps et qu'il fasse les choses
rigoureusement avec méthode voilà un
ancien chef d'état-major des armées me
disait il y a 15 ans déjà elle me disait
mais en fait n'importe qui actuellement
peut avoir 80% de toutes les
informations que dont je peux disposer
moi j'avais ta major des armes merci
beaucoup Michel Goya et pour poursuivre
cet entretien lisez donc l'ours et le
renard co-écrit c'est un dialogue
d'ailleurs avec le journaliste Jean
Lopez aux éditions paira vous restez
avec moi c'est accueillir nos affranchis
pour leur parti pris ils vont vous faire
réagir on les accueille tout de suite
mettre Bertrand Perrier qui
manifestement va nous parler quoi d'un
coup de colère qu'il a envie de pousser
ce soir un petit peu quand même allez et
puis et puis on va retrouver Richard je
le disais Richard verlique qui suit pour
nous le sommet de Vénus à tout de suite
on ne Déroche pas à la règle on commence
par Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée et bien c'est Elsa qui nous
l'a raconté elle dans mon Agava bonsoir
avant bonsoir je vous raconte l'histoire
d'une demande de sanction à l'Assemblée
ce matin c'est une information LCP les
présidents des trois groupes de la
majorité ont envoyé 7 lettres à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
Aurore berger pour renaissant Jean-Paul
Mattei pour le modem et Laurent Marc
Angélil demande des sanctions contre des
députés qui ont été présents à la
manifestation pour Adama Traoré dans
leur argumentaire les présidents de
groupes de la Majo rappelle que ce
rassemblement il était interdit que les
députés y portaient leur écharpe et
qu'ils sont restés alors qu'il y avait
des slogans tels que tout le monde
déteste la police accompagne cette
lettre donc la liste des députés
présents dans le viseur donc de la
majorité ces images regardez c'était
samedi effectivement des députés de la
nupesse présent lors du rassemblement
interdit place de la République à Paris
aux côtés de la sœur d'Adama Traoré on a
fait réagir Éric Coquerel il était
présent samedi on le voit sur ces images
place de la République
Éric Coquerel est-ce que c'est la place
d'un député d'être dans une
manifestation interdite où on entend des
slogans comme tout le monde déteste la
police en tout cas c'est pas le rôle de
la majorité de l'Assemblée nationale de
décider ce qui a droit de l'action d'un
député sa liberté d'expression ça c'est
les électeurs donc c'est pour ça que là
il y a une rouge qui est en train de
franchise j'espère que Madame brunes
Pivet va envoyer balader tout ça parce
que en réalité c'est la majorité qui une
fois de plus décide de la manière dont
l'opposition peut s'opposer quel est le
droit d'un député et bien ça c'est pas
elle de le décider c'est des lignes
rouges franchit les unes après les
autres ce qu'on voit Myriam c'est qu'il
y a un débat politique et que le
gouvernement ne retient pas ses coûts
qu'on les a soumis mais là ce qui est
nouveau c'est que la majorité elle veut
que l'assemblée s'en mêle et sanctionne
les députés elle cite dans la lettre un
article du règlement l'article 70 qui
sanctionne des manifestations troublant
l'ordre oui mais normalement le
règlement il est pour ce qui se passe à
l'assemblée
qui publie en communiqué commun qui dit
son effarement suite à cette demande qui
revient un canard rectaire inédit
puisque l'acte incriminé est politique
et a été exercé à l'extérieur de
l'Assemblée la nuit pêche qui bénéficie
d'un soutien assez inattendu regardez je
suis totalement opposé à l'idée de
sanction de député vous voyez à la
différence de tous les autres la France
insoumise comprise d'ailleurs j'ai des
principes et comme j'ai des principes je
les applique aussi à mes adversaires
politiques je considère que les seuls
qui peuvent sanctionner des députés ce
sont les électeurs pour des faits
évidemment et pour des activités qui
sont des activités politiques
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire la
présidente Yael Brown Pivet alors la
présidente elle s'est montrée très
sévère à l'endroit des députés qui
avaient participé à cette manifestation
interdite déjà en avril dernier dans un
contexte social compliqué elle avait
rappelé dans un courrier à tous les
députés que la fonction de parlementaire
se trouve dégradée lorsque les chartes
tricolores est porté à mauvais escient
ou dans des postures dégradantes elle
l'a rappelé normalement à l'extérieur
c'est de la responsabilité du député
mais pour elle il est inconcevable que
des députés ne respectent pas la loi
alors il y a un bureau vous savez c'est
l'instance collégiale de décision de
l'assemblée qui est prévue mercredi 19
juillet peut-être que cette question des
sanctions elle pourrait être évoquée ça
va vraiment vraiment pas réchauffer les
relations entre la présidente et la
nupesse la nupesse qui adore et déjà dit
que si jamais elle était sanctionnée
bien elle irait devant tous les recours
judiciaires possibles
devant les tribunaux bon on va pas vous
demander votre avis d'avocat Bertrand va
tout de suite enchaîner avec Vilnius on
prend la direction de la Lituanie où
vous nous attendez Richard Werly on sait
que la question de l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN et dans tous les
esprits alors c'est pas pour tout de
suite bien évidemment mais Hélène ski
qui est présent attend un signal clair
je crois qu'il voit Joe Biden demain si
je ne dis pas de bêtises alors à quoi
peut-on s'attendre sur ce processus de
demande de Kiev bien ce que je vais
faire Myriam c'est vous faire le récit
de la journée parce qu'il y a ce soir
devinus on a pu le voir tout à l'heure
au centre de la capitale lituanienne où
volody mirzuelinski a pris un bain de
foule il s'est fait applaudir par des
milliers de personnes et il avait avec
lui un drapeau ukrainien qui était
ramené de backmouth la ville martyr d'un
côté la ferveur populaire et ce soutien
massif à l'Ukraine et à sa lutte de
l'autre et bien ici au centre de presse
de l'OTAN c'est les nécessités
diplomatiques c'est un langage calculé
au cordeau dans le communiqué attendu de
l'alliance qui sera publiée demain ce
texte il dit que le temps intégrera
l'Ukraine quand les Alliés seront
d'accord et quand les circonstances
seront réunies on sait qu'il reflète la
volonté de Joe Biden de se montrer
prudent sans doute donc le ménager une
marge de manoeuvre entre les Etats-Unis
et la Russie alors ce communiqué il
dispense néanmoins l'Ukraine de
certaines étapes obligatoires pour
adhérer il va renouveler le soutien des
alliés à se tenir aux côtés du pays mais
il n'y a pas de calendrier il y a une
solidarité supposée sans faille alors
volodieslinski il ne va pas repartir
bredouille loin de là Emmanuel Macron a
confirmé la livraison par la France de
missiles de longues portées scalp on
sent bien aussi que la fourniture des
avions F16 tellement demandée par Kiev
devrait finir par ce matérialiser voici
quelques jours le président américain
aussi accepté de fournir des bombes à
sous-munition ici à l'OTAN l'Allemagne
la Norvège la Pologne la République
tchèque tous ces pays à liés ont promis
des armes à Kiev sauf que l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui elle veut des garanties vos
lodimir Zelinski qui est en train de
dîner en ce moment même avec les alliés
il en a besoin vis-à-vis de sa
population il en va du moral d'une
nation c'est ce soutien moral à long
terme que les alliés vont devoir demain
mercredi prodigués au président
ukrainien avec des mots qui doivent
frapper
merci beaucoup pour ce décryptage
Richard Vernier va tout de suite se
tourner vers Michel Goya il veut des
garanties de sécurité et le sait très
bien Zelensky qui va pas rentrer tout de
suite dans l'OTAN ça veut dire quoi
concrètement rien ne se fera avant la
fin de la guerre est-ce qu'on peut
donner des garanties de sécurité au-delà
du soutien militaire
les garanties de sécurité alors c'est
une notion assez floue il faut quand
même rappeler que normalement la
l'Ukraine de loi bénéficier de garantie
de sécurité depuis 1995 et la signature
du mémorandum du Budapest où elle avait
dit voilà nous nous acceptons enfin plus
exactement demander à l'Ukraine de se
débarrasser de ses armes nucléaires en
échange et un certain nombre de
signataires dont la Russie mais les
États-Unis puis plus tard la France
d'ailleurs et la Chine avait dit nous
garantissons la sécurité de l'Ukraine
bon on a vu le résultat effectivement
les garanties de sécurité c'est un pour
l'instant c'est un concept assez flou
mais on se projette sur réalité déjà sur
la prière sachant que la absolument
aucune idée de ce que sera là déjà c'est
pour ça la de cette fin de guerre
refusent de parler de calendrier ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils sont
d'accord pour une entrée sur le principe
mais on ne dit pas quand parce que ça ne
peut pas se faire tant que ce conflit
n'est pas fini oui alors déjà on est
dans situation quand même très inédite
d'un pays qui demande à adhérer à l'OTAN
alors qu'il est en guerre ça c'est
jamais arrivé il y a eu des dates
situations on peut bizarre on a refusé
par exemple à Chypre ou à l'Irlande
l'entrée dans l'OTAN parce que les il y
avait une situation de conflit de
l'attend et que le pays était partagé
mais on l'a accepté par exemple pour
l'Allemagne en 1955 on dit bon
finalement la République fédérale
allemande elle peut rentrer dans le
temps là mais le pays partagé il y a
toujours il y a pas de traité de paix
officiel etc mais bon c'est pas grave
donc on peut malgré tout s'adapter tout
est affaire de réalité de de politique
je terminerai simplement en disant voilà
il faut quand même rappeler qu'il y
avait un tournant qui a été raté en 2008
que il aurait pu à ce moment-là il y
avait toutes les conditions pour faire
rentrer le temps
j'allais dire l'OTAN dans l'Ukraine
c'était le cas après mais faire rentrer
l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN et que c'est des
pays comme la France l'Allemagne qui s'y
sont opposés assez fortement à l'époque
de la Russie est-ce que tout ce
processus aussi lent soit-il et
diplomatique est-ce qu'il faut craindre
les représailles de la Russie le Kremlin
qui a déjà dit que l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN aurait des
conséquences négatives rien que des mots
ou plus que ça rien que des morts
la Russie ne peut plus rien faire quand
la Finlande a dit finalement le Finlande
vieux pays neutre par excellence dit
finalement on va rentrer dans l'OTAN et
on rappellera que c'est une des
conséquences de la politique de Poutine
il peut s'en prendre qu'à lui-même
sur ce sujet il avait dit voilà il y
aura des représentes terribles contre la
Finlande ça ça va pas se passer comme ça
etc bon ben voilà ça fait un an on
attend toujours
en réalité est impuissante elle est
moins elle est moins dangereuse qu'elle
l'était é il y a encore quelques temps
merci Michel Goya on va laisser les
dernières minutes de cette émission au
coup de gueule de Bertrand Perrier parce
que manifestement ce qu'a fait Izia
Higelin cette chanteuse nous a pas plu
oui c'était à Beaulieu-sur-Mer lors d'un
festival qui s'appelle les nuits
guitares jeudi dernier et entre deux
chansons il y a Higelin s'est lancé dans
un monologue un peu délirant au cours
duquel elle a ni plus ni moins appelée
au lynchage public par les spectateurs
d'Emmanuel Macron on regarde l'extrait
et là on le ferait descendre mais avec
toute la grâce et la gentillesse que les
gens du Sud ont
là juste tout de suite
avec nos petits clous et dans un feu de
Ben
age servir et de sang
on le foutrait à terre mais gentiment
voilà un feu de chair vive et 200 et
donc évidemment consternation dans la
salle l'intervention des gendarmes et
puis après tout s'emballe l'ouverture
d'une enquête pour provocation à la
commission d'un crime elle a été annulée
d'un engagement qu'elle avait après
demain à Marcq-en-Baroeul dans le Nord
il y a une polémique sur le maintien de
son concert en Francofolies enfin une
grande polémique naît des réactions
politiques s'en suivent les réseaux
sociaux s'emparent de l'affaire elle
s'est exprimée depuis et elle s'est
exprimée effectivement hier sur
Ouest-France en disant que les propos
avaient été mal compris décontextualisés
et elle dit c'est un moment partagé
d'esprit libre artistique à ne pas
prendre au premier degré ça vous paraît
bien léger comme explication oui c'est
même assez opportunistes en réalité on
voit bien que les concerts commencent à
s'annuler et donc elle réagit et je
crois que il faut redire que
l'invocation de la liberté d'expression
à laquelle nous sommes évidemment tous
attaché de cette mission un peu
provocatrice ou contestataire des
artistes ne permet pas toutes les
outrances cette liberté supplémentaire
dont jouissent les artistes et tant
mieux ne vaut précisément que lorsqu'ils
sont des artistes lorsqu'ils ont un acte
artistique ça vaut donc pour les paroles
d'une chanson ça vaut pour le déserteur
de Boris Vian chanté par Reggiani ça
vaut pour Brassens et son gorille ça
vaut pour les déserteurs de Léo Ferré
mais donc c'est cantonné à la chanson
elle-même lorsque l'artiste n'est plus
dans son rôle et bien il n'a plus se
surcroît de liberté et là comme je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est entre deux
chansons ça n'est pas une parole de
chanson et à ce moment-là et bien on a
un peu l'impression qu'on est passé d'un
concert un meeting pourtant il y a des
précédents il y a une affiche
représentant Emmanuel Macron en Hitler
avait été relaxé et dernièrement Justine
trier aussi s'en est prêt au
gouvernement de façon très très vive sur
la question des retraites oui il s'agit
pas de dire que le pouvoir en place le
président de la République devrait être
à l'abri de toute critique mais même
vivent évidemment même virulente mais
ici c'est un peu différent parce que ça
n'est pas une critique elle n'argumente
pas il y a pas d'idées il y a juste un
appel alors avec 1000 précautions mais
clairement on l'a entendu débattre avec
des clous c'est un appel au meurtre et
donc ça la loi l'interdit il y a
quelques semaines une personne gilet
jaune qui avait crié Macron décapitation
dans une manifestation a été condamné à
3 mois de prison avec sursis donc ce que
je veux dire c'est que ce genre de
déclaration un peu à l'emporte-pièce
sous le coup de l'excitation et d'un
concert mais ça contribue quand même à
la dégradation du débat public plus de
violence c'est moins de débat et à
l'heure où il y a de plus en plus
d'agressions contre les élus et bien des
propos comme se disent Higelin ne sont
pas acceptables et le prétexte de la
liberté artistique ou du second degré ne
tient pas une seconde être artiste c'est
pas avoir un totem d'immunité pour tous
les propos que l'on tient et on pense
aux paroles de Jacques Higelin le père
disait Higelin comme on peut on tomber
plus mal merci il parle juste il parle
bien merci Maître l'ours et le renard
c'est Perrin très belle soirée sur LCP
on est un peu en retard alors à demain
[Musique]